tél
avenue de serre ok vous avez des ma
propre
oui ou fumer quand je rappelle le
règlement intérieur
on ne fume pas on ne dit pas de gros
mots on ne touche pas à la vitre si on
me parle me vouvoie et on veut parler
correctement d'accord mairie des lilas
ouais ça roule pas hyper bien méritée
car j'y serai ça dépend des pontes du
temps vous voulez mettre une ethnie à 4h
pas en argent 1 pourquoi je peux vous
faire une course spéciale n'ont pas une
minute avant que valve minutes sur des
trottoirs et ça s'emballe j'ai deux
belges ok je vais te tarifs belge alors
il ya deux ans a dit oui y'a pour les
belges ou et non puis ça depuis deux
trois mois maintenant et pourquoi parce
que comme ça on peut se faire plus
d'argent parce qu'il regarde pas le
compteur et en général on double le un
tarif avec les belges c'est quoi un
public c'est une avenue pas deuxième
cliente
la première a éclaté en sanglots au
total à ce qu'on a mis deux heures pour
aller à
un kilomètre et puis a commencé à me
casser les couilles et puis j'aime
beaucoup je me paye dans la gueule à la
mal pris webb a commencé la natation
j'ai mis une claque dans la gueule avec
ni plus ni moins 7 pouces ya ce bon
alors on va avec je sais on va passer
par créteil n'a pas recréé oui là on va
chercher mon beau frère il connaît hyper
bien paris et on va quand même un nom
même été prêtés mais je suis prêt j'ai
pas vous mettre quelque part je vais
déposer quelque part attendez je veux
dire aux âmes bien nées ou mais c'est en
japonais savent dès demain notre plan
c'est pas un truc en français un plan
français non sens japonais ça je dis pas
le japonais à moi on va faire un essai
déjà pris un essai de décharges
électriques là ce que j'arrive pas à
régler mon truc anti-agression c'est du
triphasé vous allez prendre du 220 volts
sera une seconde se prêtent voulait
serrer un mouchoir un truc certes un
petit peu mal ça dure deux secondes un
guide au sexe à donner je suis obligé -
combien j'ai mon truc qui mettent ils
vont même baisser on a
ok bon bah c'est bon oui waouh kazan
près du parc montsouris ont dit
massivement oui c'est que les mines on
dit pas mon swiss été mis là vous êtes
une faute de français la totale et un
truc de goût matin de fautes de français
ça fait deux fautes en 7 ans guy
montsouris nom m'a souri cette semaine
le pain il s'appelle montsouris parce
que c'est un bon et moralité sur
simplement à cette heure là je suis 12
j'ai fini mon service oui dans ce que je
vous demande et parce que j'ai pas de
charge et c'est de vous coucher faut pas
qu'on vous voie à l'essai couchez-vous
oui non si jamais je me go les lacets
retraite dix ans encore oui vraiment
vraiment au coffre
voilà vous êtes à l'aise la bombe ou je
vais vous appelez sultan et vous je vous
appelez vie qui comme ça si j'ai mon là
un contrôle safra genre couple de belges
allemands sultan pas bouche et on mange
une voulaient pister avant que les
jeunes sortent avant mais bon si c'est
loin
non ça va aller pas bougé un bon donne
la patte le temps de la pâte à sel bien
fait bien au pays à des chocolats
poursuit le temps il va chocolat au pays
c'est que c'est des sucres ailleurs mais
l'acteur pour moi plus le règlement
intérieur a beaucoup de mal à parler
poliment de potiche et ovi maps est
correct ok
ok ma grosse on va y aller et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus